et pour en parler nous sommes en liaison
avec stéphanie juillet secrétaire
général du collectif inter bloc s'était
fait merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur et rrt france alors on le disait on
attend des mesures dans les entreprises
pour endiguer le coronavirus le port du
masque obligatoire sur son lieu de
travail ou encore le télétravail quand
c'est possible des mesures
indispensables selon vous aujourd'hui
oui bonjour oui absolument c'était
indispensable et ça devrait même être le
cas depuis le défilement 27
le virus n'a pas cessé de de progresser
donc ce retard n'est effectivement que
tout le monde se responsabilisent et
porte le masque dans tous les lieux
donne tous les lieux clos c'est évident
et dans les deux publics
on croise monde aussi effectivement dans
l'avenue également quand les rues sont
fortement peuplées ben oui absolument
on sait que le virus se transmet par
ailleurs par aérosol les
microgouttelettes qui sont portées par
les aérosols donc forcément quand vous
croisez quelqu'un qui éventuellement ne
porte pas de masque et porteur du coc
vide et se met à tousser ou éternuer ou
non vous vous passez vous êtes
potentiellement contaminés par ces
personnes et on sait qu'il ya un nombre
très important de personnes
asymptomatiques
et pourtant porteur du virus donc
forcément très contagieux alors
concernant les chiffres le nombre de
nouveaux cas de contamination
d'infection a rechuté un sous le seuil
des 500 après avoir dépassé les 3000 au
cours des deux jours précédents a
annoncé hier donc lundi 17 août
lagence santé publique france comment
est ce que vous comprenez cette baisse
je comprends pas vraiment en fait parce
que voyez par exemple chez les soignants
ne sommes pas à dépister
systématiquement à titre personnel je
n'ai jamais eu de dépistage et j'ai pas
non plus forcément a demandé à en avoir
parce que on le sait que c'est très
compliqué pour se faire dépister qu'il
faut présenter certaines signées que si
on les a pas aidé en refuse deux mots
dépistés
donc voilà les chiffres on peut leur
faire dire ce qu'on veut en fait ce
qu'il faut voir c'est si les quatre
circulent les cas qui arrivent à
l'hôpital
et ça c'est pas une utopie ils vont
aller voir en tant que soignant les
caraïbes et donc non mais si j'ai réussi
les gradins qu'il faut être très méfiant
alors des nouveaux cas vous sentez l'âme
horse d'une seconde vague des retours
que l'on à nous avec le cjb en fait au
niveau national oui il ya certains
établissements qui commence de nouveau à
avoir des cas hospitalisés des cas
graves
donc oui effectivement ça rentre dans sa
roue et il faut savoir que au niveau
matériel on n'est pas du tout équipés
dont on est toujours au même stade
justement par rapport à ces équipements
les respirateurs artificiels par exemple
ou même les effectifs est ce que
l'hôpital est prêt à faire face à une d1
éventuel afflux de malades du colis de
guère plus que la première fois j'ai
envie de vous dire parce que si
certaines problèmes ont été réglés à
savoir que des respirateurs ont été
achetés on a toujours un problème de
fourniture de protection individuelle
donc là maintenant au maroc de commun
que obèses toujours demain à ce que les
aspects de il faut savoir qu ils sont
toujours périmés ce qu'on a on a des
masques périmés de 2008 par exemple ont
moins que et qu'est ce qu'on en dit bien
que voilà c'est partout pareil que ces
interventions qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
s'approvisionner qu'il faut faire
attention quand on doit vraiment être
vigilant sur ce qu'on consomme les blues
stérile sans stop très tendu les gosses
terry c'est pareil et nous on bloque
c'est notre outil de travail donc
forcément si on en a plus on m'a donné
ça va être très problématique nous on
pourra pas se protéger des sacs poubelle
pour opérer les gens quoi c'est pas
possible donc on se demande où est la
préparation encore une fois alors quel
est le moral du coût du personnel
soignant déjà fortement éprouvée par le
premier épisode mais là le personnel je
vous cache pas que tout le monde est
épuisé on y entre nerveusement et
physiquement très fatigué et je pense
que de ce qu'on entend beaucoup de
professionnels ne sont pas prêts à
revivre ce qu'on a déjà vécu la première
fois donc je
je ne sais pas du tout comment ça va se
passer chez moi je moi je suis
personnellement assez inquiètes à lescar
alors mais pour vous est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres paramètres à prendre en compte
ce qui n'aurait pas été évoqué d'autres
mesures à appliquer pour davantage se
protéger d'une propagation du virus et
pour davantage d'efficacité à l'hôpital
les mesures barrières les connais tout
le monde les connaît on en entend parler
tous les jours il ya des spots et des
spots publicitaires qui passe tous les
jours donc les gens s'ils n'ont pas
compris je sais pas ce qu'il faut faire
après maintenant les masques
chirurgicaux en ces cas n'a donc il faut
les mettre pourquoi ne l'est mais
pourquoi ne pas les mettre c'est ça
associé à une hygiène des mains de ces
mesures barrières qui ferait un qui font
tout quoi donc je comprends pas que les
gens sont encore réticents alors certes
on nous a menti on nous a fait croire
que c'était pas obligatoire au début je
pense que les voir et les enquêtes
merci on aura bien entendu respect des
gestes barrières port du masque il faut
faire toujours très attention merci
stéphane huet elle je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire général du collectif un
père blanc